[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم في المقابله في
الحلقه الثانيه مع العلامه الدكتور يوسف
القرضاوي المثقف العضوي كما يقول جرامشي
هو المثقف الذي يؤثر ويتفاعل مع القضايا
المحيطه به وهكذا هو حال عالم الدين في
الاسلام الشيخ القرضاوي لم يكن اسيرا
لمكتبه هنا وانتاجه العلمي وكتابته
وعلاقته البعيده بالناس بل كان عالما
ومثقفا متفاعلا ومؤثرا بالقضايا التي تحيط
به في هذه الحلقه نركز على قضايا الربيع
العربي الثورات حال الامه مواقف الاخوان
المسلمين ومستقبل هذه البلاد البلاد
العربيه والبلاد الاسلاميه حسب رؤيه الشيخ
الدكتور يوسف
القرضاوي
بعد الاحتلال الامريكي للعراق عام 2003
والثوره السوريه في 2011 شهد البلدان
انهيارات في بنيه الدوله دفعت الناس الى
محاوله ايجاد بدائل لها من خلال العوده
الى هوياتهم القوميه والدينيه والطائفيه
والقبليه وبرز خلال هذه الفتره تشرذم
المسلمون السنه وعدم وجود داعم وممثل
سياسي لهم واصبح هناك صراع على تمثيل بين
دول وجماعات وفصائل
مسلحه ينظر الى حاله الانقسام هذه
باعتبارها امتدادا لظروف تاريخيه واقليميه
قديمه اثرت في الحاضر فبعد انهاء الخلافه
العثمانيه عام 24 من القرن الماضي فتح
المجال امام دول وجماعات ومنظمات لمحاوله
ملء الفراغ وتمثيل المسلمين لا سما السنه
منهم خاصه بعد احتكار ايران لتمثيل الشيعه
عقب ثوره
الخميري في عام
1928 اسس حسن البنا جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين لتكون بمثابه ممثل للسنه خاصه
وان تاسيس الجماعه جاء بعد اربعه اعوام من
اعلان نهايه الخلافه الاسلاميه لكن
الجماعه لم تنجح في تحقيق طموحاتها بتوحيد
المسلمين لا على المستوى السياسي ولا
الفكري تاسست خلال تلك الفتره جماعات
اسلاميه مختلفه في فتره اعتبرت صحوه
اسلاميه دينيه حاولت من خلالها جماعات
مختلفه مثل حزب التحرير والتبليغ وغيرهما
ملء الفراغ وتمثيل المسلمين السنه لكن كل
تلك المحاولات لم تنجح في وراثه تاثير
الوحده السياسيه التي كانت ممثله في
الخلافه العثمانيه والثقل الديني الذي كان
يمثله الازهر في مصر والزيتون في تونس
وجامعه القرويين في المغرب وغيرها من
المدارس السنيه التقليديه
التاريخيه امتداد لمحاولات تمثيل المسلمين
والصراع على هذا التمثيل اسس الشيخ يوسف
القرضاوي في عام 2004 اتحاد علماء
المسلمين ليكون للمسلمين كافه بغض النظر
عن ق قومياتهم ومذاهبهم فشمل ممثلين
للمذهب الجعفري
[موسيقى]
والاباضية من دائره اهل السنه والجماعه
وحظي المؤتمر بانتقادات واسعه من هيئه
كبار العلماء في السعوديه اضافه الى
انتقادات من قبل الشيخ يوسف القرضاوي نفسه
والذي اعتبر المؤتمر محاوله لشق وحده
[موسيقى]
المسلمين مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم مجددا
في هذه الحلقه الثانيه من المقابله مع
فضيله العلامه الدكتور يوسف القرضاوي في
الحلقه الاولى تناولنا شيئا يسيرا من من
سيره الدكتور يوسف القرضاوي ومراحل حياته
الاولى في هذه الحلقه نحاول ان نركز على
مجموعه من القضايا الملحه اليوم في عالمنا
العربي مرحبا بك شيخنا مجددا وسعداء بهذا
الوقت الذي تتيحه لنا كنت من العلماء
الذين امنوا بالربيع العربي والذين دعموه
ونصروه ووقفوا مع المنتفضين والمحتجين في
في اكثر من بلد عربي لماذا اتخذت هذا
الموقف دكتور يوسف
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا رسول الله وعلى
اله وصحبه ومن اتبع
هداه وبعد فالعالم المسلم وجزء من امته
المسلمه لا يجوز ان يظل العالم في واد
والامه في واد
اخر العالم في مقدمه
الامه العالم همته ان يبعث الامه ولا
يتركها تكلها الذئب
ورسها هؤلاء الذين لا يخافون الله ولا
يخافون
الاخره ولذلك كان لا بد ان نتجاوب مع
الامه حينما
بدات هذه بدايه الربيع العربي واول ما بدا
الربيع العربي بدا في ثوره
تونس حينما بدات ثوره تونس قلنا نحن مع
تونس وكنت اول من وقف مع
الشباب تونس بدات
كانت
منذ جاء بورقيبه
واحتل منصب القياده فيها عزل
الاسلام
عن التوجيه وعزى الاسلام عن القياده وعزى
الاسلام عن السياسه وعن التفكير وجاءه احد
اتباعه
فعزله وعزل الاسلاميين
ايضا ثم جاءت هذه الثورات الاسلاميه كنا
منتظرين هذه الثورات هل تراها ثورات
اسلاميه نعم لكن لم تكن ذلك بمعنى الذين
خرجوا شيخ يوسف لم يتحدثوا عن الاسلام او
او عن مكانه الاسلاميين او مكانه الاسلام
حتى في الدوله تحدثوا عن الحريه والكرامه
والعيش والديمقراطيه وهذا ما يدعو اليه
الاسلام اول ما يدعو اليه الاسلام ان يعيش
الناس في امان الذي اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم
من
خوف شوف يعني المس الطعام من الجوع
والامان من الخوف الكفايه والامن والحريه
اه والحريه هي ضمن الامان لكن الاسلام لا
لا امان بدون بدون حريه ولذلك فهذا ما
يدعو اليه الاسلاميين او نظره الاسلامين
فيها تقيد الحريه لا يرون الحريه مطلقه
لديهم نظره خاصه لا ما معنى الحريه الحريه
ان تفعل ما تشاء ولا تفعل ما
ينبغي تفعل ما ما تشاء يعني تقتل الناس
يعني ليس عندك اشياء محرمه هذا لا يقول به
احد انما ان تفعل ما ينبغي للانسان العاقل
انه ما يحتاجوا اليه الناس من الحريه حريه
العقل حريه النقد
حريه
التصرف الحريه السياسيه الحريه الدينيه
لكن الاسلاميين لديهم تصور لما ينبغي
يختلف عن تصور بقيه الناس ما ماذا يريد
الناس من من
الحريه الناس ماذا يريدون من الحريه هناك
وجهات نظر كثيره شيخ يوسف في موضوع الحريه
ولكن عند تيارات فكريه ليبراليه يساريه
يعني تختلف عن ولكن هل الحريه ان ان كل
مجموعه تفعل ما
تشتهي اليس هناك موازين
عامه اليس هناك قيم
متفق عليها حينما قال عمر بن الخطاب ماذا
استعبدتم الناس وقد ولدتهم امهاتهم احرارا
بيحكم
بالفطره متى استعبدتم الناس وقد هذه
الحريه التي لكنك شيخنا كنت ضحيه الحريه
حينما اجتهدت في الفقه ايضا وجد وجدت
تيارات داخل الاسلام بشكل عام رفضت
اجتهادك قيدت حريتك لان لديها موقف سلبي
من التفكير انا لا لا اريد من الحريه ان
يتفق كل الناس عليها لان هذا مستحيل ان
يتفق الناس على اراء واحده هذا لم يحدث
ولا للرسل الرسل ناس استجابوا لهم وناس لم
يستجيبوا لهم يعني هذا معروف ولذلك فان لا
اريد ان كل الناس يتفقوا مع يقولوا
القرضاوي هذا لا ليس ولكن انا اقول عقلاء
العلماء العلماء الذين يفهمون معنى العلم
مع مع الشيء المعصوم والشيء غير المعصوم
معنى المقدس
وغير المقدس معنى ما جاء به الله ورسوله
وما جئنا به من من
عقولنا معنى المجمع عليه والمختلف
في هذه
الامور يعني تقلب على وجوهها المشكل اللي
بيدخل فيه ناس في هذه القضايا ولا
يفهمونها يذكرون اشياء
يشوشون على الناس دون ان يصلوا بالناس الى
الحقائق الاوليه انا اريد ان ادعو الى
الاسلام والى الاجتهاد في الاسلام ليس
معنى ان اقول الناس تعالوا للاسلام يعني
قال الله تعالى
و طيب سؤال اعتراضي شيخ اذا سمحت لي ما
قام به ف فوده وابو زيد هل تراه من الحريه
الفكريه ام تراه تجاه
الحريه المتمرده هذا يعني ولكن مع هذا انا
افتح لهم الباب اللي نتحاور
معهم تعالى ماذا تريد يا فرد فوده ماذا
تريد يا ابو
زيد هؤلاء لابد ان يناقشوا لانهم يريدون
يعني احيانا يريد
تمويه الموضوع واخراج الموضوع عن البحث و
طيب انا اريد ان ابقى في موضوع الربيع
العربي شيخ انت تحدثت
بشكل متكرر عن عن حسنات التجربه التركيه
تجربه العداله والتنميه والاسلاميين في
تركيا وعن اردوغان الزعيم التركي البارز
وكنت قد قابلت الرئيس اردوغان في اول حلقه
من هذا البرنامج وقال لي امام الكاميرا
انه ذهب الى مصر وتحدث مع الاخوان
المسلمين عن وجوب اعتماد النظام العلماني
وانه وجد قبول وجد موافق اريد ان اسال راي
العلامه الدكتور يوسف القرضاوي عن شكل
الدوله عن هذا النمط من
العلمانيه النموذج التركي على سبيل المثال
كيف
تراه انا اؤيد رجب الطيب
اردوغان رجب الطيب اردوغان رجل
المامون
يفكر
ويستشير ويسال
ويتعلم من الحياه ومن الناس ومن التجارب
وليس رجلا
منغلقا المنغلق هم الذين يخيفون ان واحد
ينغلق على افكار ولا يريد ان يتغير
عنها هذا
هو المغلق هذا هو المشكل اما ان واحد عنده
فكر ويتردد في هذا الفكر ويسال عنه ممكن
يغير يعني بعض هذا الفكر وحينما يشرحه لك
تجد انه قريب مما عندك فتراب به لان نحنا
لا نريد ان نباعد بيننا وبين الناس كلما
وجدنا من الناس من يقترب منا وان لم يكن
مثلنا 100% ممكن في خلاف بسيط
ف نفسح فيه بس النظام العلماني ليس خلافا
بسيطا النظام العلماني المعتمد في تركيا
وليس خلافا بسيطا هو هو اختلاف كبير جدا
بين يتحدث عنه الاسلاميون من نظام للدوله
او الحكم وبين القائم الان في تركيا ما
ماذا يقول اردوغان في النظام العلماني هو
يرى وجوب اعتماده هو يؤمن به ويرى انه
يعمل ضمن الظام العلماني و وكان ينصح
الاخوان المسلمين في مصر باعتماد
العلمانيه طريقه لاداره
الحلا ما معنى العلمانيه اص تفسير هذه
الامور مهم جدا العلمانيه ب
بمعنى انه
يتساوى فكر الناس وشرع الله هذا مستحيل ان
ان ان تكون هذه مقبوله انما ان يتاح للعقل
الانساني ان يفكر يبتدع الناس لا بس
العلمانيه ان الدوله لا دين لها ولا تتحكم
بالدين في المجال العام هي مجرد
مؤسسات مستقله محايده في موضوع الدين اما
انها لا دين لها لا نستطيع ان نقول ان
الدوله المسلمه لا دين لها كيف وهي دوله
تدين بالاسلام ومن يبتغ غير الاسلام دينا
فلن يقبل منه هنا شيخ و في الاخره من
الخاسرين لا التوضيح فقط اردوغان يقول
يقول نحن مسلمون لكن النظام الحاكم في
الدوله نظام علماني اما نحن كشعب وانا
كشخص يتحدث عن نفسه هو مسلم بلا شك وبل
واسلام النظام ماذا يلزمني هل يجعلني ارفض
يعني ان ال المراه لا يجوز ان تتزوج غير
مسلم يعني اذا كان الاسلام يقول هذا ماذا
ما ماذا اقول
انا هل يلزمني ان اتي بكافر على مسلمين
وهم الاغلبيه
يعني ما ما ماذا يعني يقول هذا النظام
العلماني يقول ان الناس متساوين المواطنين
متساوين لا فرق في دينهم او مذهبهم او او
في اي شيء او في عرقهم الى اخره في لا لا
لا شك من حيث المطالب حيث ان الانسان يريد
ان ياكل ويشرب وان يلبس وان يكون له حق
الحريه في التعبير عما
يريد كل ناس مش المسلم اللي له الحق وغير
المسلم يرفض حقه لا نقول المسلم مثل غير
المسلم
بل التشديد على حق غير المسلم اكثر من
المسلم لكن حقوقه منقوصه هو لا يتولد
رئاسه الدوله الولايه العامه الولا كيف
يعني يتحكم في مسلمين اذا كان واحد في بلد
اهل مسلمين كيف يتحكم يعني غير المسلم في
امه مسلمه يعني هذا يعني ليس من المعقول
هذا بمعنى هو ان الامه المسلمه كيف تحكم
غير مسلم في دينها وفي شرعها ما هو هذا
الخلاف في اساس الدوله شيخ يوسف اساس
الدوله ان المواطنه اعلى من الدين لا من
قال هذا هذا ما يطرح لا لا لا هذا
المواطنه ليست اعلى من الدين المواطنه جزء
من الدين الدين الرسول حين
ذهب الى
المدينه المنوره
و ودد هناك يهود ودد هناك مشركين ود هناك
مسلمين فجعل الصحيفه الصحيفه اللي ماثبت
الدستور دستور يجمع الكل يقبل المسلم
بالاسلام ويقبل اليهودي بيهودي ته
ويقبل القبائل المختلفه قبلتها فوسع ال
الجميع وسع المواطنه شيخنا حتى فقط لا
اذهب بعيد عن نقطه الربيع العربي وعن ايضا
وصفك لانها ثوره
الاسلاميين او انتفاضه الاسلاميين البعض
يرى ان الاخوان المسلمين في مصر على وجه
التحديد كانوا سببا في الثوره المضاده وفي
الانتكاسه التي حدثت بمعنى بادارته طريقه
ادارتهم
تعهداتهم التي لم يصدق يلتزموا بها حينما
قالوا لن نترشح الرئاسه ونزلوا تحالفوا مع
المجلس
العسكري ما تقييمك لدور الاسلاميين في
الثورات العربيه في مصر ومن بقيه البقيه
اولا انا لا
التزم بالاخوان ولا التزم الدفاع عنهم في
كل ما فعلوه وكل ما قالوه انت عارف انا
موقفي يعني لست من الاخوان تنظيميا حش
الزم اشرنا له في الحلقه
الماضيه ولكن انا ممكن ادافع عن الاخوان
في بعض ممكن تنتقدهم لان الدفاع واضح يعني
هل ممكن تنتقدهم ا تنتقد ادائهم في في في
اشياء قال الاخوان انهم
لن يترشحوا للرئاسه وكان يظنون انه ستكون
هناك شخصيات
اسلاميه عامه ليسوا من الاخوان ولكن من
الناس المقبولين
عند مجموع الامه ا عند عموم الناس اه ولكن
للاسف هؤلاء الناس لم يقبلوا ان يترشحوا
طارق
البشري
دكتور العوه ترشح سليم العوه ا او يعني
طرحوا انفسه من الاخوان محسوبين على
الاخوان
انما الاول قالوا عايزين حد من غير
الاخوان ف انت دعمت ترشح ابو الفتوح اه
لماذا لانه الاخوان تركوه فاصبح من غير
الاخوان فيبقى شخص مقبول يعني وارضيته
اسلاميه لا مانع ان اخطا الاخوان في عدم
دعم ابو الفتوح برايك في رايي انهم كان
يجب يقبل ابو الفتوح لكنه بعدين اتخذ
مواقف سلبيه جدا
هم
الاخرين
لما لم يجدوا امامهم مرشح
اسلامي قاللك احنا ما نسيبش بقى العمليه
نرشح حد من قبلنا فرشح خالفتهم خالفتهم
شيخ في ذلك لا انا لم يسالوني يا حبيبي
انا لم اكن يعني اصد لا كراي يعني اعتقدت
انهم على خطا لا لو سالوني لا قلت لهم انا
لما سؤلت رشحت عبد المنعم ابو الفتوح
واخترته في اول الامر ولكن لما وجدت
انه الامور بقت فيها مش معروف مين اللي
هيكون
في و وترشح ناس
لا امنوا له ودت ان الاولى ان اقبل مرشح
الاخوان اللي هو الدكتور محمد مرسي
الدكتور محمد مرسي ولم اكن اعرفه والله ما
كنت اعرفه انا قلت له لكن كانت لك كلمه
مسموعه يا دكتور ا نعم في مصر وفي غيرها
لكن في مصر على وجه التحدي انا
و ونح الدكتور مرسي واعتقد الدكتور مرسي
ظلم ظلما يعني كبيره لماذا لانه لم يتح له
من اول يوم يا دكتور لم يتح له ان يعان
فتره من الزمن حتى يملك يعمل شيء من اول
اسبوع و وبداوا يعني في المحاربه له يعني
هو النظريه انه حكم العسكر 60 سنه حكم
الاخوان سنه هي المشكله حكم العسكر مصيبه
امتنا حكم العسكر اين اخطا الدكتور وبعدين
الال لما يعود حكم العسكر حكم عسكري واحد
يجي يحكم الامه ويسير الامه كما دي اصبحت
مشكله الامم اصبحت بتملك امر نفسها وعسكر
يحمي الامه وكل واحد يوضع مش اظن يوصل
لهذه المشكله الى الى
اليوم محمد مرسي رجل لما عرفته عرفته رجل
صدق ورجل يخاف الله ورجل يعمل لمصلحه
الامه وكان مع مع مع هذا التضيق بدات
الحياه تنفسها لم نرى هذه المصائب ورا بعض
ورا بعض ورا بعض مصائب ورا ورا كان كان
يسخر من الدكتور مرسي وهو رئيس قسم
الهندسه وحاصل على الدكتوراه يعني قياسا
على من جاء بعده ومن جاء قبله الاعلام
المصري عمل بشكل منظم يعني لكن اين اخطا
الرئيس مرسي برايك اخطا الرئيس مرسي
حينما اصر على ان
يظل هشام قنديل ده رئيس الوزاره والناس
رفضاه لماذا يا اخي فرض واحد الناس مش عاه
الناس مش عايزاها
هذا اخطا الرئيس مرسي في انه وثق
بالسيسي
وتاله انه رجل من عباد الله الصالحين وهو
يخدعه يجي قدامه ويسال مراته الاولاد صلوا
العشاء صلوا في المسجد ح فضلوا على جماعه
وبت الحمد لله ويسمع صاحبنا الحمد لله
الحمد
لله
اردوغان ارسل الى محمد مرسي قبل الانقلاب
بشهر واحد يقول له يا دكتور مرسي كل
المعلومات التي عندنا تؤكد ان السيسي لا
يعمل معك يعمل ضدك ابحث عن هذا الامر
فهو طيب هذا ليس خطا الاخوان ان يرشح
رئيسا لمصر يا دكتور خيرا مش وثقين
برجالنا دكتور اليس خطا الاخوان ان يرشحوا
رئيسا مع تقديرنا لظروفه الان ووجوده في
المعتقل في مرحله صعبه من عمر مصر والامه
رئيسا بهذه القدرات ايضا الا يبدو ان
الاخوان تيار لا يملك تجربه لا يملك معرفه
لا يملك نضجا كافيا لا كل المصريين يقع
يقع منهم مثل هذا من في المصريين عندهم
مثل محمد مرسي محمد مرسي وخياره الشاطر
وعبد المنعم الفتوح
ومحمد العوه وكله هؤلاء كلهم رجال اي واحد
منهم يعني يستطيع ان يقود البلد ولكن لما
تيجي الواحد ولا تترك له فرصه من اول
يوم كل اللي حكم محمد مرسي سنه سنه هل
تركوه شهر يا دكتور ما تركوه شهر واحد
ازاي يبدا يشغل الناس يخلي الناس تشتغل
بدا وزير التموين يشتغل بدا الوزير الشباب
يشتغل بدا عيده وزراء يشتغلوا
وينتج يرى الناس اثارهم مش هؤلاء اللي جوم
من اول يوم والناس تنزل من سيء الى اسوا
ومن اسوا الى الاشد سوءا
وهكذا الجنيه اليوم بس تذكير شيخنا 19
دولار ب 19
جنيه ما الفارق بين اسلاميه مصر واسلاميه
تونس برايك
ا الرجال هنا غير الرجال
هنا اخونا راشد
الغنوشي
رجل يعني عرف الحياه وعرف الناس
وعنده يعني قدره على الاتصال وان كان يسرف
احيانا في بعض هذه الاشياء احنا نظن
الظنون الحسنه اكثر من اللازم يعني
بالايراني
وذهب معهم طويلا يعني وانا انتقدت يعني
يعني في هذا ولكن معرفته بالحياه اكثر من
المصريين ولذلك لم يقبل هو ان
يدخل يحمل رئاسه الدوله وكان ممكن بسهوله
نعم من رساله الدوله ابى وق اضل انظر
وا احكم واقول اعملوا كذا واعملوا
كذا
ف لم يكن
وبعدين تونس بلد يعني صغير عشر مصر مصر 90
مليون تونس 10 مليون يعني تعقي هنا اكبر
في مصر ها التعقيدات اكبر التعقيدات اكبر
ثانيا حكم مصر اهم طبعا وبالتالي الهجمه
الدوليه كانت ايضا اكبر الذي يملك مصر غير
الذي يملك سوريا غير الي يملك تونس تونس
تركت
رقيبه وغيره انما وفاهمين ان
و
فال الفرق كبير بين طيب عتبت على الشيخ
الغنوشي في موضوع الايرانيين انت يا شيخ
يوسف دعوت سنوات طويله للتقريب والحوار
وكنت تذهب الى ايران وانشات اتحاد العلماء
المسلمين واتيت بتسخير نائبا لك ممثل
المذهب الشيعي ايضا انت الم ترتكب نفس الخ
اذا كان خطا الم ترتكب نفس الخطا
لا
انا عمري ما قلت ان هؤلاء يعني يجب يعطون
كل شيء ويجب ما قلت هذا لما تذب تمسك
كلامي تلتقي كلامي ماذا كنت تقول محبك
يعني ف دائما كلامي في
حبسه في يعني
تقييد انا لما
ذهبت الى ايران وهم اللي دعوني
الى ايران وقلت لهم يا جماعه يعني احنا
لكي يكون التقريب الذين دعوتم اليه تقريبا
صحيحا ومعمولا به وماحدش عيب علينا فيه
لابد ان نرعى الامور
في انتوا بتقولوا التقريب لماذا لا
يسمحون بالمساجد لاهل السنه يكون لهم
مساد
السفراء سفراء البلاد الع العربيه
والاسلاميه من سنين
بيطالبو قالوا ولماذا لا يصلون في ماردا
يا اخي انتوا مالكوش مساجد انتوا لكم
مساجد هنا حد لكم مساجد في انتم كل اللي
عندكم مسجد واحد الجامعه بيصلوا في انما
المسلمين يحتاجون الى مساجد في كل
مكان قلت لهم انه ايضا التشيع نشر التشيع
كما تحدثت اكثر من مره اتهمته بانهم لم
يلتزموا لم يلتزموا
ال كذلك يعني
ا
المسلمين هناك في جماعه اسمهم اهل السنه
في مصر الجمعيه
الشرعيه اصحاب اللحا
وال فلهم مساجدهم بيصلوا فيها صلاه
خاصه يطولوا الصلاه ولكن الله يلزمو الناس
احنا مساجدنا وهذه
طريقتنا لازم نصلي كذا صلاه قبليه وصلاه
بعديه ووتر في العشاء وكذا
وكذا انتوا لماذا تلزموا الناس بما لا
يلتزمون به وذكرت لهم اشياء كثيره ما يعني
ما ما تركت لهم ا الامور عيمه خالص يا
دكتور يعني انا ذا انا حضرت لهم
اربعه
مؤتمرات مؤتمر في الرباط اول مؤتمر
ومؤتمر ثاني في سوريا ومؤتمر ثالث في
البحرين والمؤتمر الرابع في
قطر وفي كل مؤتمر اذكر بعض الاشياء التي
ينبغي ان ترا
ولا يراعون لا تراعى وبعدين جيت في قطر
وقلت يعني يبدو ان
يعني ان ما دعونا اليه لا نجد له استجابه
يجب وضع الامور في نصابها وتوضيح الامور
للمسلمين عامه وقلت الكلام ده وبداوا بقى
يعني
يهاجموني احدى الوكالات هناك عملت عل
مشكله لم ابالي انا بهذا وبدا التسخيري
يهاجمني وفضل الله
يهاجم فضل الله كلم يعني طلع معايا كمره
في
في الشريعه والحياه مرتين وبعدين المره دي
قعد قال القرضاوي يعني ما هاجم
ال التنصير
وهاجم قلته قلت من قال يا يا شيخ حسين فضل
الله ان انا لم اهاجم التنصير انا هجمت
التنصير لما قالوا التنصير عمل في سنه
1976 في كولورادو
هو مؤتمر ودعا الى تنصير العالم الاسلامي
قمت انا دعوه العالم الاسلامي قلت لجب
المسلمين يعملوا هم قالوا هنعمل تنصير
للعالم الاسلامي وجمعوا 1000 مليون دولار
قلت المسلمين ليه ما يجمعو 1000 مليون
دولار لو انه كل مسلم دفع دولار
واحد من 1000 مليون نجيب 1000 مليون دولار
طيب شيخنا ما الاشكاليه في ان يقوم الناس
بالدعوه او بالتبشير لمذاهب واديان اذا
كان المسلمون اليوم يقومون بحملات دعويه
في افريقيا وفي اسيا كل شخص لديه دين حسب
منطقه يدعو فما المشكله في ان يدعونا
للتشيع او للتنصير او للاسلام كفكره يؤمن
بها الانسان كل واحد بيدافع عن دينه ا انا
كمسلم اجد
انه
الشيعه للاسف لا
يدعون النصارى ولا يدعون اليهود يذهبون
للسنه ولا يدعون المشركين ولا يدعون
الملاحده ولا الشيوعيين كل من يدعون السنه
يدعوا السنه في البلاد المختلفه ليصيروا
شيعه هذا هذا كلام وهذا واضح احنا
ارسلنا 40 داعيه الى افريقيا بعد ما حصلت
ما حصل ده بعثنا 40 واحد وهؤلاء الارعين
الداعيه جاؤوا كل واحد منهم بتقرير ان
الشيعه لهم في كل بلد ناس وكل واحد مه
يعني
فلوس
ودعاه مصر ما عرفت التشيع واصبح فيها الان
شيعه نعم مصر ما عرفت التشيع في العهد
الحديث الان اصبح في عدد من الشيعه في مصر
مصر قعدوا يعني
مده اكثر من 30 سنه يحاولوا ان يدخلوا مصر
وكان في ناس في الصعيد اسمهم
الجعفره هم جعفره نسبا منسوبين الى جعفر
الصادق ولكن مش المذهب حاولوا انت له ما
يكونش على
مذهب لم يستطيعوا ان يدخلوا واحدا من
هؤلاء 30 سنه الى ان
جاء الخميني وبدا الناس وبدا الناس يعملوا
اهل البيت مذهب اهل البيت وذب يعمل كذا و
ويطلعوا كتب ويعملو في
الصحف شيخنا انت تراس الاتحاد العالمي
لعلماء المسلمين ويفترض فيه ان يكون جهه
يعني يتوحد خلف جهه دينيه شرعيه احوال
المسلمين ليست بخير اليوم على الصعيد
المذهبي وليس الصعيد السياسي الشيعه في
جهه السنه في جهه السنه وانقسامات داخل
الدول العربيه السنيه تدين جماعات اسلاميه
سنيه وتراها ارهابيه القاعده تنظيم الدوله
المؤتمر اللي حدث في الشيشان ومحاوله عزل
السلفيه ايضا عن عن عموم المسلمين وعن
قياده
[موسيقى]
المسلمين ما هي الوصفه الحل اليوم اذا كنا
نتحدث او كان الوضع على هذا النحو اليوم
ما هي وصفه الحل لايجاد حل لهذه المشاكل
هذه الخلافات والانقسامات بين
المسلمين والله حل هذه الانقسامات
ان يعرف المسلمون انفسهم من
هم المسلمون مقدرون في العالم بمليار و700
مليون مع ان هم اكثر دايما القوى اللي
بتعد
المسلمين بتحاول تقلل عدده طيب مليار و700
مليون ماذا يفعلون اليوم كلها كوارث
وازمات واحتقان وحروب
طائفيه
الذي الامه عليها تنظم نفسها اذا كان هناك
استجابه لاهل العلم
والفكر الامه تريد ان تبني نفسها الامه
مهما يعني تهاوت ومهما
انطمست لابد ان ياتي لها يوم تحيا لابد
القوي يض الضعيف يقوى لابد الميت يحيا
لابد للانسان تخضر اوراقه مش هيفضل ذابل
طول العم وهكذا نراه ف هل تراها امه امه
طبعا في كتابك انه انه الامه الاسلاميه
حقيقه لا وهم شعوب مختلفه شيخ متباينه
ظروف مختلفه ولكن بينها رابطين ديني في
رابط تجد اللي اللي عندك يعني هنا في قطر
تجده في السعوديه تجده في مصر تجد في في
ماليزيا تجد في اندونيسيا تجد في تركيا
الهم واحد
الامه هي اللي بتقول الحمد لله رب
العالمين الامه اذا اصابتها مصيبه يقول
اللهم ارفع هذا عنا يا رب
العالمين التي تقول لا اله الا الله محمد
الامه هذه امه واحده انا كتبت
هذا الكتاب امه الاسلاميه حقيقه لا واححد
حقيقه
لاوه ودللت على على هذا
وقومت
طيب السيد ياسين
تبع الاهرام في كلامه و ولست انا الذي
اقول الامه الاسلاميه الامه الاسلاميه
حقيقه فعلا في هو حينما تحلل الافكار
السائده في الامه الافكار التي تتفق عليها
الامه تجدها واحده عند الامه
الاسلاميه في ناس صحيح يعمل ولكن ليسوا
اغلبيه الامه شيخنا امنت بالربيع العربي
ايدته كما ذكرنا والان المشهد على النحو
التالي هذه الانتكاسه الكبيره في سوريا
الانتكاس الكبيره في مصر في
اليمن الا يبدو ان الاوضاع كانت ربما تكون
افضل لو لم يحدث هذا الربيع العربي برايك
لا لا كان لابد ان يصير هذا
العربي يا اخي ربنا اللي بعت هذا الله
طبيعه الناس كانوا بيغلوا في مصر قبل حتى
ما ما تقوم سوريا انا كنت اشوف الشباب وهم
يعني وانا بدات الشباب ده هم لسه قبل ما
يعلنوا كنا كنت انا
في في الازهر وقد اختاروني عضوا في مجمع
البحوث وكبار العلماء و كنت بذهب واشوف
الشباب دولا و وانا راجع من الازهر ورايح
الى فندق المريديان اجت كان معايا الشيخ
سلمان العوده كل ما نذهب الى مكان نجد
مغلق الشباب نروح مكان ت انيق مغلق يعمل
بتاع والشباب شافوني وجوم يجروا ويقولوا
قهم كونوا اقوياء يثبتوا ما تيجي تنزل معه
ق والله اتمنى ولكن انا معكم ليش ما نزلت
معاه وفعلا قبل ما امشي القيت تصريح لمجله
لجريده الشروق انا مشيت يوم الخميس من مصر
ونشر يوم الجمعه قلت لهم اثبتوا ولا
تتخلوا وكان هذا من ط وبدات اسير
الى الجزيره في كل كل يوم اصر نعم كنت معك
في في مره من المرات الحاسمه شيخنا اعتذرت
للسلفيين في موضوع حزب الله لعلماء
السعوديه وقلت انك اخطات انهم كانوا يعني
اصحاب كان نظرتهم كانت اصح الا يمكن ان
يحدث هذا الامر مره اخرى مع بعض المدارس
السلفيه التي ترى بعدم وجود وجوب الخروج
على ولاه الامر وان هذه الفتنه التي كانوا
يخشونها
انما حدثت اليوم هذا السيل من الدماء الا
يمكن ان يحدث مثل هذا الامر لا لا لا في
الناس في السلفيين ايضا يعني هم
مثل الشيعه بس
بالتضاد
هذا لا يمكن يعني ومنهم خرجت القاعده
ومنهم
خرجت داعش و خرج من مثل هذه الافكار
السيئه التي
تحارب العالم وتقتل الناس بطريقه
غير هؤلاء لازم نبين انهم اخطاوا وانهم لم
يحسنوا فهم الاسلام ولا بد ان يعني لا لا
يعني نفسر الاسلام التفسير الصحيح الذي
تقوم عليه الحياه الحياه الان ما عادش
الانسان يستطيع انه يعيش في زاويه لوحده
او ياخد له ركن في العالم ويقعد ما عادش
يمكن هذا العالم اصبح تقدر تلف العالم كله
وترجع الى المكان ال الذي انت فيه والدنيا
تغيرت ولازم كل واحد ياخد حقه احنا
الاسلام الذي ندعو اليه هو الذي يسير
بالعالم لانك تعطي الناس حقوقهم اول ما
تريد ان تقيم الاسلام في الارض اعطي للناس
حقوقها ما تقولش اسلام وتسيب الناس ميتين
من الجوع ايو اسلام هذا
لا يرضى هذا لا لا سيدنا عمر ولا سيدنا
ابو بكر ولا محمد رسول الله سيدنا عمر لما
جاءه
الراجل يشتكي يعني ن سيده ما بياكلو قاله
اذا جه يشتكي مره اقطع ايدك انت
يعني وفي لما الناس قامت المجاعه اوقف
الحد الحدود انما تقوم عندما ياكل الناس
الجائع ياكل والخائف يامن وكل واحد ياخذ
حقه من غيره هذا هو الذي ياخذ عليكم بعض
الناس انك انت والشيخ سلمان العوده مجموعه
من العلماء والرموز والدعاه كانت لكم
علاقات جيده مع الحكام الذين ثارت بلدانهم
ضدهم القذافي بشار الاسد زين العابدين
وامتدحت بعضهم يعني في في فترات قريبه
ليست بعيده عن و وحكام بلاد
الخليج انا كنت قريب جدا من
الملك عبد الله الملك فهد
دعاني ابنه
ا اسمه عبد العزيز ولاير عبد العزيز دعاني
في احد الرمضانات يعني وبعت لي انه قلت له
ده انا في رمضان بقود الناس بصلي وكذا
وبتاع قال لي احنا عايزينك يا اخي اربعه
ايام يعني قلت له خلاص باقي ورحت اجي و
وسلمت على ايه بس حكام الخليج لم تقم ضدهم
ثورات نعم انا اقصد بشار الاسد زين
العابدين القذافي ولكن هناك ناس تقول عنهم
ما تقول وبعد بعد وسلمت على الامير فهد
وبعد ذلك و ج الامير عبد الله دعاني
و كنت والله تعبان ولكن قلت والله لازم
اذهب
وذهبت وسلمت عليه الشيخ دكتور عبد الله
التركي قدمني له وقال له الشيخ القرضاوي
كان مريض ولكن لما وصلتك دعو وصلته دعوتك
قال لابد
ان اكسر المرض واحضر وقال له يا اخي وليه
تسيبوه مريض ما عندنا مستشفياتنا لماذا لا
يعال هذا الملك عبد الله الملك عبد الله ق
انا ادعوه انه يطلع من هذا المؤتمر يذهب
الى ذهبت فعلا الى وبعدين حتى حتى هو قال
لشيخ الدكتور التركي قال له بعد ذلك نزوده
واحده يعني كان وكان علاقته هذه العلاقه
مع الحكام شيخنا ما تخلق شبهه وكل حكام خ
الا تخلق شبهه العلاقه مع شخصيه عالم
السلطان او علماء السلطان لا احنا لا
الكلام ده لو لو بمشي عشان عشان اقول كل
اللي يعمله اقول هذا هذا لا يحصل مني ابدا
لا اقول على كل ما يقوله الحاكم
انا الشيخ
ا حمد بن خليفه
وهو امير
جاء بريز وسلم عليه وتبعا انا قلت على
المنبر ان الذين سلموا على بريز يجب ان
يغسلوا ايديهم سبع مرات احداهن
بالتراب يتطهروا ك ز بي زعل عليك الخنزير
زعل عليك وانت عندك علاقه معه لا بالعكس
لما رحت كان كان قبل قبيل العيد رحت بعد
العيد مك يوم سلمت عليه وبتاع وقال لي انا
والله غسلتهم 14
مره شيخنا في نهايه هذه الحلقه وقد تجاوزت
ال 90 ومسيره طويله من العلم والدعوه
والعمل والمواقف السياسيه والصراعات
والجدل وانتاج اكثر من 150
مؤلف اكثر من 200 اكثر من 200 انا قلت
عندي
وعندي الان المجموعه التي يعدها يعني فيها
هتكون حوالي طيب يعني 50 مجلد ماذا تود ان
تقول بعد هذا كله للناس للذين احبوك وتبعو
والذين خالفوك
وهاجموه الين اتفقوا واختلفوا معك والله
شوف
اولا انا
متصدق
بعرضي لكل
مسلم اي مسلم صادق في اسلامه وهاجمني
لانه لا
يعرفني انا
مسامحه اذا لم يكن
عميلا ل شيوعيه او شيعيه او مذهب باطل او
اذا لم يكن عميلا وكان ينطلق من نفسه انا
مسامح للجميع وانا اقول للجميع انا في هذا
كله والله لا اصدر الا عن كتاب الله وسنه
رسول الله واخلاق الصحابه وافكار الصحابه
الامه الاسلاميه الاولى في القرن الاول
خير القرون القرني ثم الذين يلونه القرن
الاول هم الذين نستفيد منهم ونقتبس منهم
نحن ندعي الامه الى اسلام الامه الاولى
ليس يوجد اسلام الا اسلام الامه الاولى
اعظم ايه جاء بها النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وما ارسلناك الا رحمه
[موسيقى]
للعالمين الاسلام رحمه للعالمين جميعا
لهذه الدنيا
كلها الشرق والغرب والعربي والعدم كل
الناس جاء الاسلام لخدمته جميعا ونحن
علماء المسلمين اذا كنا علماء حقا
ندعو
بالقران وبالسنه ونتعلم من علمائنا الكبار
وهم اهل لان يعلموا العالم اذا كنا احقاء
بهذا الدين علينا ان نتمسك به وندعو الامه
الى التمسك به ان تستمر الامه في التمسك
بهذا الاسلام ولا تجز عنه والله لن يحي
الا من موات ولن يجمعها من من شتات ولن
يوقظها من
سبات لن يقضها من سبات الا هذا الدين اذا
احسنا فهمه واحسنا الايمان به واحسنا
العمل له واحسنا الدعوه اليه واحسنا تدميع
الامه كلها عليه اذا احسنا هذا سنصل الى
ما نريد ونصبح امه الاسلام وكذا ذلك
جعلناكم امه وسطا لتكونوا شهداء على الناس
ويكون الرسول عليكم شهيدا فضيله العلامه
الشيخ الدكتور يوسف القرضاوي ممتن جدا
لهذا الوقت الذي منحتني اياه وزملائي في
برنامج المقابله في حلقتين
ا تكاد كل واحده منهم ان تلمس شيئا فسيره
طويله لا يمكن اختصارها في في هذه في
هاتين الساعتين مهما طالت شكرا جزيلا لك
شيخ بارك الله فيك
الشكر موصول لكم انتم مشاهدينا الكرام على
طيب المتابعه نلقاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل دمتم بخير والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[موسيقى]
وبركاته